.
WE HAVE A LOT MORE COMING UP,
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY OF
LOUISIANA BUT FIRST TONIGHT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS FIGHTING BACK
AGAINST BIG TECH AND TODAY HE
ANNOUNCED A BRAND-NEW CLASS
ACTION LAWSUIT AGAINST FACEBOOK,
TWITTER, AND GOOGLE.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE ARE ASKING THE U.S.
DISTRICT COURT FOR THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF FLORIDA TO ORDER AN
IMMEDIATE HALT TO SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES'S ILLEGAL, SHAMEFUL
CENSORSHIP OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
WE ARE DEMANDING AN END TO THE
SHADOW BANNING, A STOP TO THE
SILENCING AND A STOP TO THE
BLACKLISTING, BANISHING, AND
CANCELING THAT YOU KNOW SO WELL.
IF THEY CAN DO IT TO ME, THEY
CAN DO IT TO ANYONE, AND IN FACT
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
THEY ARE TAKING PEOPLE OFF WHO
DON'T EVEN REALIZE THEY WERE
TAKEN OFF.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHY THEY ARE
>> Sean: A TEAM OF
HIGH-POWERED ATTORNEYS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOW TAKING
AIM AT WHAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED AT
LENGTH ON THIS PROGRAM, SECTION
230 PROTECTIONS.
IT'S ENJOYED BY MANY BIG TECH
GIANTS BECAUSE SUPPOSEDLY THEY
DON'T INVOLVE THEMSELVES IN
EDITORIAL, BUT IN REALITY THEY
DO.
OF THIS SECTION 230 IS A LEGAL
LIABILITY SHIELD AND IT PROTECTS
THESE PLATFORMS -- THEY ARE NOT
CONTENT PROVIDERS ANYMORE, THEY
ARE EDITORS -- FROM BEING HELD
LIABLE FOR THE CONTENT POSTED BY
THEIR USERS, BUT THEY EDIT.
BUT OTHER TWITTER, FACEBOOK,
YOUTUBE, ET CETERA, ARE ALL
EDITORIALIZING CONTENT WITH
SO-CALLED FACT-CHECKERS AND
EVERYTHING.
FACT CHECKS THE FACT-CHECKERS?
AND WARNING LABELS EVEN
SUSPENSIONS FOR THINGS THEY DEEM
INACCURATE EVEN WHEN THEY'RE
WRONG OR NOT UP TO THEIR
POLITICAL STANDARDS, THEN
SHOULDN'T THESE TECH COMPANIES
BE TREATED LIKE ANY OTHER NEWS
EDITORIAL OUTLET?
AFTER ALL, EVEN FAKE NEWS CNN,
MSDNC, THE THREE BROADCAST
NETWORKS, "NEW YORK TIMES,"
"WASHINGTON POST," THEY DON'T
FALL UNDER THE SECTION 2:30
UMBRELLA.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT LIABILITY
PROTECTION.
MEMBER THE SAME SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES CENSORED WHAT WAS
NOW -- WE NOW KNOW WAS
COMPLETELY ACCURATE.
THAT WAS "THE NEW YORK POST"
REPORTING ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN'S
LAPTOP FROM HELL BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
WHY DID THEY DO IT?
TO PROTECT JOE BIDEN AND HURT
DONALD TRUMP.
IF YOU CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO QUANY
IN TERMS OF DOLLAR DONATIONS HOW
MUCH IN-KIND MONEY THAT MEANT TO
JOE BIDEN'S CAMPAIGN.
AND NOW THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, DONALD TRUMP, HAS
BANISHED COMPLETELY.
HE IS BANNED FROM TWITTER AND
FACEBOOK AND YOUTUBE, BUT GUESS
WAS NOT BANISHED?
LOOK AT THIS, THE SUPREME LEADER
OF IRAN.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THE AYATOLLAH.
HE FREQUENTLY TWEETS ABOUT DEATH
TO AMERICA, DEATH TO ISRAEL,
OFTEN CALLS FOR THE
EXTERMINATION OF "THE JEWS,"
STATE-SPONSORED TERRORISM.
AT JACKET TWITTER, I GUESS ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE HIM.
IRAN'S MOUTHPIECE IS ALSO ON
TWITTER, HE'S ALSO VERY ACTIVE.
MULTIPLE FAKE NEWS PROPAGANDA
OUTLETS RUN BY THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA.
A FEW MONTHS AGO WHILE
CONSERVATIVES -- YES, A LOT OF
MY FRIENDS -- WERE GETTING BAND
LEFT AND RIGHT, MY TEAM WON'T
EVEN LET ME HAVE ACCESS TO MY
SOCIAL MEDIA AND HAVEN'T FOR A
LONG TIME BUT AS CONSERVATIVES
WERE BEING CENSORED FOR TWEETING
ABOUT, OH, THE WUHAN LAB LEAK,
CHINESE PROPAGANDA ACCOUNTS WERE
SPREADING AN INSANE CONSPIRACY
THEORY ACTUALLY ACCUSING THE
UNITED STATES AND OUR SOLDIERS
OF PERSONALLY PLANTING COVID IN
WUHAN.
IN THE VIROLOGY LAB THEY HAD
ACCESS TO THAT?
AT JACKET TWITTER, CARE TO
COMMENT?
BY THE WAY, NOTORIOUS
ANTI-SEMITE RACIST LOUIS
FARRAKHAN, HE'S ALSO STILL ON
TWITTER.
HE'S NOT BEEN BANNED.
YOU KNOW, DESPITE RHETORIC ABOUT
THE WHITE DEVIL AND "JEWISH
TERMITE," VERLYN ANTI-SEMITISM,
THERE'S SOMETHING FUNDAMENTALLY
WRONG WITH IT COMPANY THAT BANDS
ARE DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES BUT GIVES AN
ENORMOUS PLATFORM TO AMERICA'S
FOREIGN ENEMIES AND OTHER
DISTRIBUTABLE INDIVIDUALS.
AND AS PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST
STATED, IF T